[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon everyone
my name is Senne che and the software
engineer on the amp project and today
I'm going to share with you our secrets
for making web pages stuff and hopefully
you learn some of the best practices and
apply them in your own development
process but first let me show you what
problem we're trying to solve this is a
typical mobile page and I as a user want
to see this page I have just clicked on
a link to open this page and read the
content but I can't because there are
things that are preventing me from doing
so the first is that it's extremely slow
to load in fact does anyone here in the
audience know how long it takes the
average mobile page to load 15 seconds
15 seconds you know that after 3 seconds
half your users are gone after 10
seconds nobody's there 15 seconds is
horrible the average is 19 seconds so
after I finally loaded my page I have
this flash of unstyled content which is
very jarring and could possibly give you
a Pepsi and after I takes forever to
load I have a flash of unstyled content
I start reading the page in 20 seconds
later when it's just that the best part
and I want to see what happens this ad
loads out of nowhere and fix my content
around and I lose my
place and I don't know where I am
anymore and I really want to know what
happens next so then I try to look for
where I was but now my browser is kind
of frozen or it's janky and I can't find
where I left off this is a horrible
horrible experience we have all been
here before but why should you as
developers care about this you have a
million things you could be doing with
your time why is it important to fix
these issues well my answer is that it's
important if you want to keep your users
and your revenue today I'm going to take
you under the hood and show you what's
going on that's causing all these issues
I'm going to show you the 10 sets that
we take with amp to address these issues
to make the web experience much better
and hopefully you'll be able to apply
what we do in your own development
process to make your pages better in
faster so first let's look at the first
problem which is that it's very slow to
load and what's happening here is that
there are things that are blocking the
render and these things happen to be
files that you have to download before
you could see anything on your page they
could be the assess files they could be
JavaScript files and they have to
download and it takes a really long time
and to solve this we decided that we
need all scripts to be asynchronous so
that you can see the HTML on your page
you can have the page load and the
script will load in the background and
they don't have to block the render of
your page the next thing is that we only
want to download JavaScript that you
need on your page so here for example is
a carousel not every page will have a
carousel so not every page should
download the JavaScript of a carousel so
we break the page up into components and
we tell the browser specifically what
JavaScript we
want to download so that you only
download what you need for your page the
next thing is that we inline CSS so
external stylesheets tend to be very
large and they take a very long time to
load so in lining it means that you
don't have to download them separately
and it's going to be a lot faster this
is like taking a carry-on luggage with
you when you fly it's going to be a lot
faster than if you check in your baggage
and end up being one of these people
waiting at the carousel nobody wants to
be here because it takes forever so
check in your don't check in your
luggage carry it on with you inline your
CSS now when you fly and you take a
carry-on suitcase with you you have to
limit how many things you bring right
because you don't have room for your
entire house in your carry-on luggage
and we decided that we're going to limit
CSS by 60 kilobytes and 50 kilobytes is
just like the space in your carry-on
luggage it's just enough for all the
things that you need but you're not
going to bring a bunch of junk that you
don't need the next thing so also the 50
kilobytes what it forces you to do is
clean up CSS that you don't longer need
now around wintertime a lot of us have
these promotions for for Christmas or
for the holidays for certain sales and
we have CSS for it and then we get rid
of the we don't show it anymore because
you know in January Christmas is over
but someone forgot to clean up the CSS
it's still there even if your users
don't see it but they're paying for it
with their time because it takes longer
to download and their wallets because
this takes up data so limiting CSS to 50
kilobytes means that you're going to
have to clean up these things and it's
going to give your users a much better
experience the next thing I want to talk
about is third-party JavaScript and
mainly
in relation to ad so ad have not all
kept up with the time and a lot of them
think that they need third party
JavaScript for their execution and
because ads are important and they make
money we have to allow them to exist and
so they use third party JavaScript but
we we have to tell them they need to be
in sandbox iframes because third party
JavaScript does horrible things first
they write think script so again you
have this issue where you have to wait
for these scripts to load before you
could see anything on your page the next
thing is that they document dot write
more things script so you have a lot
more Singh script that you have to wait
for and it all adds up and the third
thing that they do is style
recalculations
which is very heavy on the CPU because
they have to scan your entire page and
it also might be wrong because if you
name a CSS class the same thing an ad
could potentially change the style of
something on your page such as your logo
and you don't want that so by limiting
third parties to these sandbox iframes
they're still going to do these bad
things but they're not going to affect
the rest of the page they're not going
to affect the load and they have their
little box where they can play and also
doing salary calculations are going it's
going to be a lot cheaper because it's
only going to scan the content of the
iframe rather than your entire page this
is like allowing your toddlers to play
with paint and you know that they're
going to make a mess you just want to
keep that must away from other parts of
your help
the next thing we do is resource
prioritization so a typical mobile page
is a lot longer than then your viewport
then your first viewport of a phone and
sometimes we don't actually download the
entire page when a user taps on it but
the
our perceive the load to be
instantaneous because we load the
content in the first viewport before we
load the rest of the page and this makes
the perception of the load
instantaneously even if we didn't have
the time to download everything and we
also do something called pre connect so
for example here's a YouTube video and
to lo the contents of a YouTube video
there are a lot of things going on but
one of them is we have to connect to the
source right we have to connect to
YouTube and that takes up time so by
connecting ahead of time as we know that
there's a YouTube video or an image or
for example with Twitter to load the you
know the content you have to connect to
one server to load images you have to
connect to another server by doing these
connections ahead of time when it comes
time to load the content it's going to
load much faster so now we've gotten rid
of this slow loading problem but we're
not done because we have this flash of
unstyled content and we don't want this
and what's happening here is that the
page is loading but then the styles are
being applied after the page has loaded
and to solve this problem we use an
invisibility trick and we set the
opacity of the body to zero so it exists
but it's invisible to the user and then
the styles are applied and eventually
the JavaScript will load and unhide the
page so to the user it's perceived as
being loaded like this first but what
happens if there is no JavaScript well
we have this no script to unhide the
body if there's nothing there to unhide
the body and then finally what if
JavaScript servers go down which can
happen everyone's in a couple of years
right and to address this issue we do a
CSS timeout animation timeout so
for some reason the page thinks that
there is a JavaScript that the server
times out then we will have a timeout
that will unhide the body if the
JavaScript never arrives
now what I just described to you it's
what we currently do but there is a bit
of a time delay and we're currently
working on doing server-side rendering
so that there will be zero time delay so
now we reload fast we got rid of the
flash of unstyled content but we're not
done because 20 seconds into reading
this ad loads out of nowhere and shifts
the content all around and nobody likes
it and what's happening here is just
like I talked about earlier is that I'd
use these third parties Java scripts and
they're really slow they take forever to
load we can't force all the ads to be
implemented in a way that they're going
to load fast right we can't force them
to do that but we have to allow them to
play so to solve this problem where we
let them exist but don't punish our
users we put these placeholders because
we know that there's going to be an ADD
and we have static resource sizing so we
know the size of the ad and so the user
can read the contents of the page and
then it's up to the ad to load on time
and eventually the ad will load and it
won't shift the content so the user can
continue reading and have a pleasant
experience and we've solved this content
shifting issue but we're still not done
because we need to address this frozen
janky problem that's happening and
what's going on here is that the CPU is
overworked and overloaded and to address
this we do a few things first is that
style recalculations are really
expensive so we want to minimize style
recalculations
and we do so by caching the coordinates
so we know where all the things
our and then we know when things resize
and that's the only time that we're
going to recalculate the style
also we batch the dome access so for
example I have this code sample where we
measure something and then we set the
height we change the zone and then we
measure something again and then we
change the zone by setting the width and
then we measure something again and this
is a very reasonable chunk of code but
what's happening here is that the style
is being recalculated every time you
measure something because the dome has
changed
so by batching the dome access we can
schedule a read for the first animation
frame and then we can schedule a write
for the next animation frame so that you
only recalculate the style one time in
this example and this is going to be a
lot less expensive for the CPU so we
have a max of one style recalculation
for spring and this is the main thing
that makes amp pages fast when you
interact with them this is really the
only thing you can afford if you want to
get to 60 frames per second and we only
do two style recalculations for a page
load which is very low compared to other
pages the next thing is that we want to
do GPU optimizable animations only in
our in our amp components so animations
are very expensive for this CPU and we
want the CPU to the handover the work to
delegate the work over to the GPU
because the GPU can do animations really
quickly and really cheaply and so in our
amp components we only allow animations
that the GPU can perform in this case
it's transform and opacity so if you
wanted to animate the width the GPU is
not going to know how to do it and it's
going to say CPU you go ahead and do
this so we don't allow width or height
animation
but we do allow transform and opacity
because the GPU knows how to do this and
it can do it very cheaply so now we've
gotten rid of the frozenness and janky
nice but I want to take a moment so
everything I talked about now any
developer can do you can apply in all of
your development processes but because
we're talking about amp amp also uses a
cache so if you wanted to build a system
it's a little bit more complicated but
you can optimize with cache and what we
do is first of all the cache we have
servers that are located in lots of
places all over the world so they're
physically located next to you and that
means that delivery of the content is
going to be a lot faster when these
servers are located next to and these
servers they could be Google servers or
they could be CloudFlare servers it
doesn't matter but that's going to give
you that real boost of speed is to have
this cache and some of the optimizations
that we do on the cache is the first is
efficient pre-rendering the browser is
used to have this thing called a rel
equals pre-render where you could tell
their browser you could have a link on
your page and you could tell the browser
hey download pre-render this link so the
browser would download all the contents
of the page and and then when the user
would click on the link the page would
load instantaneously but the problem
with this was that it downloads the
entire contents of the page all of the
images all of the ads all of the
analytics so the third party JavaScript
and it would R execute arbitrary
JavaScript in the background and that's
very heavy for the CPU so instead what
we did is we pre render only the first
viewport and we don't execute any
third-party JavaScript so none of the
analytics and all that stuff and what
this does is it makes pre-rendering
extremely cheap and non expensive
the next thing we do is resource
compression and by resource I mean all
the things all the files that the users
are going to download on to their page
and some of these files are JavaScript
files and so we use a closure compiler
to compress our code and here's a chunk
of code on the list and if you run it
through the closure compiler it's going
to compress it to the chunk on the right
and on top of that oh it also does tree
shaking so it gets rid of dead code and
methods that aren't being used and so on
and we have our own optimizations that
we do on top of the closure compiler so
we get rid of developer codes such as
blogs that you only use for development
but your users they shouldn't have to
download those lungs because they're not
going to be useful so we get rid of
those as well on our main page on the
HTML we use a compression algorithm
called brought Lee and that saved us 8%
over gzip which is another compression
algorithm and then finally I want to
talk about images because images make up
64 percent of the bytes of an average
mobile page that's huge so if you can
effect images you can have a huge impact
on the size of the page so we compress
images the first thing that we do is we
remove invisible data this is metadata
that your users don't see such as
geolocation and so on and we also we
reduce the quality of the image and we
try to have one color sample for every
four pixels and this reduce the image
size by 40 bytes on top of that in for
browsers that support WebP II which is
another image format such as JPEG we
convert the images to WebP II and that
reduces the images further and then for
Chrome users that have data saver
enabled or places in the world where
data is extremely slow we lower the
quality of the images even further to
save more bytes so now when we apply
these
three things on an image let's look at
the before and after so before we have
two hundred and forty thousand bytes for
the left image and the right image has
25 thousand bytes that's about a 90%
reduction in bytes and keep in mind
images make up 65% of your page so
that's pretty big and you might look at
it and say you know what I don't like
the image on the right it's not as good
I could tell the difference but I want
to tell you that actually I switched
them so the image on the right is the
before the image on the left is actually
the after so now to summarize everything
if you haven't paid attention or if you
just walked in to make webpages faster
we want to unblock the render by making
sure that scripts are asynchronous so
you don't have to wait for them you want
to bring your CSS with you you want to
inline it and you want to limit it to 50
kilobytes and third javascript is
third-party javascript is okay but you
want to put them in iframes
so they don't affect the rest of your
page and you want to prioritize your
resources you want to load the things
that the user is going to see first also
we use opacity magic to make sure that
this doesn't happen and we're going to
do server-side rendering in the future
so that there isn't even a tiny bit of a
delay and you want to stop shipping by
having placeholders and static resource
sizing so that your users don't suffer
from this atrocity that I'd usually
commit and then you want to unfreeze
your page by giving your CPU space to
breathe so less cell recalculation and
let the GPU do the animations and then
if you can do cache optimizations and do
cheap pre-rendering and compress your
page so let's see how we're doing 19
seconds for the average mobile page to
load and less than one second
for Ambon search and what does this mean
well it translates to 10x less data we
have higher CTR publishers are saying
higher CTR and higher ad viewer ability
and today there are about 2 billion amp
documents from about 900,000 different
domains so hopefully if you apply some
of these things you can see similar
benefits as well and if you don't want
to do all of that work you're welcome to
use em now I know this is Jay's cons and
you all love JavaScript so you might not
want to use em because it doesn't
involve writing a lot of JavaScript so
I'm here to tell you that you're welcome
to write progressive web app and use em
for content delivery and that way you
can write lots of fancy JavaScript and
if you're passionate about what we do
and you want to help out amp is an open
source project and we welcome
contributors there you're welcome
to work on the project with us and
create m components to learn more about
the m project please go to EMTALA org
visit our youtube page if you want to
contribute bitly slash health amp and
right after this we will be at the am
booth if you'd like to meet our team
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]